[MUSIC]
>> Exceptional leaders,
the ones who come to mind
when you think about people you
admire is that they are known for
continuing their development
throughout their lives.
Folks who take a growth mindset
see the challenges they're
facing as something that they
could develop enough to achieve or
overcome or master or learn from,
so that a failure from
a growth mindset perspective
is an opportunity to learn.
The typical approach is to be judgmental,
to think of what's happening
as somehow inevitable and
then to worry about assigning blame for
all those things that are going wrong.
If we can develop more
of a growth mindset,
we can do a much better job
of creating in ourselves,
a set of capabilities that can
make us more successful precisely,
because we've run in to
difficulties in the past.
So at all levels, exceptional leadership
for you as an individual, for
the organization of the people you
touch there and for the world.
All have to do with whether or
not you take a developmental approach, or
a judgmental approach.
How do your actions as a leader
affect the growth mindset of others?
What can you do to make it, so
that your workplace is more
developmental and less judgmental?
>> Transform your Approach to
Leadership Excellence and Development.
Learn more about SEP,
the Stanford Executive Program.
[MUSIC]